[Music]
everybody welcome to a totally not
filler episode of koala Beach you might
notice that I'm alone I don't have the
lady's honor or really rain come out in
here today since this has been a bit of
a hectic chaotic week for one today
designers still doesn't have a computer
so she can't record anything which is
why I'm quickly taking this over but I
don't really have that much time this
week so this is all very last-minute and
correctly and really ranked now also
can't be here unfortunately and yeah
that's just about all the issues that
we've got going on so we've got a bit of
a mediocre little filler episode and I'm
the only one to guide you through this
situation yeah that's that's basically
what's going on so I did decide to do
something on the park file it's not to
much but there were a couple of things
which I left unfinished in the last
episode and also a couple of things
which I still need to try since the last
episode so in that sense it is kind of
good that we have this little in-between
thing where nothing really big is
happening but at least I can get back to
what I was working on in episode 22
which I I really just had to cut off
because it was taking a super long time
to record that episode and even with
cutting stuff out of it it became a very
long episode so what are we doing today
well for one I wanted to add a couple of
slides most prominently a multi-lane
racer slide which was also pretty often
requested and also a small family slide
because that's something that I felt was
kind of necessary and just for the heck
of it a nice little curvy simple slide
which is a little bit smaller than the
curvy slides that we have so far now
only the curve d1 will be enclosed the
rest are just going to be some more open
slides so that kind of fits the weather
as well the only problem is that I don't
really want to make any open curved
slides since the only way you can make
that is out of the smallest
our pieces that you have in the game and
those pieces are still extremely big and
still make your slides look very very
low pony in a way it's just very blocky
so I wanted to avoid that kind of look
and just built these multi-line razor
slides instead another thing which I'll
be getting to later in this video is
kind of fixing the parts which I sort of
left unfinished for the other slides as
you might have noticed I left them
unfinished a little bit in the last
episode they don't have like any details
on the top whatsoever
so even though they have a skim out or
run out whatever you want they don't
actually have that little place where
you enter the water slide I'm not
quickly sure what the actual jargon
board is but that's something that I
still had to add as well as some general
detailing around the water slides to all
make it look a little bit better now for
the multi-lane races lines we are kind
of going for the very standard design a
couple of funky colors that are very
bright a little bit too bright maybe and
three small hills so I have to say each
here is consecutively a little bit
larger and has slightly larger curves as
you're picking up some speed over these
lanes the hills also just kind of get
bigger but hopefully you can actually
catch some decent waterslide airtime on
that last hill and waterslide airtime is
seriously that's worth it so another
thing which was quite interesting and I
really have to give a shout-out to Liam
lizard on this cord who sent me quite a
few messages of him trying to build
water slides just for me to critique and
kind of give some feedback on but one of
his ideas was to actually sink some
water slides into a cure water and build
some scenery around that and even though
it takes a lot of trial and error to
kind of get it exactly right and make
sure that it's all clean it does give
you a water texture for those run outs
which looks a little bit fancier
especially if you're looking from the
side and you can really see that water
texture shine like that so I think it
adds quite a lot to it and I think it
was too important added too
the endings of the regular water slides
especially since those are raised anyway
but for this family slide and for the
multi line racers they usually land in
these these very shallow large areas so
I think this is something we're using
that method of sinking them into actual
water and just kind of building around
that using terraforming and scenery
works quite well so on the side here
we've got the family slide which is one
of these large wide slides which pretty
much the entire family can just go on
I'm personally not too big of a fan of
these slides they're kind of boring but
they work well for families and for kids
and you can write them with multiple
people at a time it is pretty cool
they're also quite good for doing all
kinds of stunts prior to recording this
episode I actually did have a bit of a
look back on a youtube channel called
tube slides one or tube slides if you
will which is something that I used to
watch quite a bit actually it's
literally just a channel with videos of
water slides but it's all the videos are
really well made but it's also just fun
to watch all of these different water
slides there are so many of these things
out there especially compared to roller
coasters and so many weird quirks and
variations especially in all kinds of
European regular sort of City swimming
pools and it's actually so pretty
interesting stuff to look at now this is
also where I drew quite a bit of
inspiration for the water slides problem
in terms of what I wanted to have in the
waterpark since we've kind of got oops
the sort of standard array going of
regular closed I guess they call it up
no I completely lost my inner tube water
slides or we also have the multi lane
water slides we have the family slides
and those are really some three of the
very common types of water slides there
are a couple ones that I've been
thinking about but haven't really
you know if I want to do it and if so
how I'm going to do it in the future
though I didn't really have time to do
it for this episode but the other type
that sort of been thinking might be cool
to get into are either the water slides
with I'm not even sure what you would
called me you might know there are the
spinal variations or the toilet bowl
kind of water slides which God English
is hard but it's something that I've
been thinking about but it's kind of
hard to get it right also a master
blasters would be amazing these water
slides that launch upward or any kind of
really the wider kind of water slides in
general the thing about water slides is
that there are a crazy lot amount of
different types and very much like
coasters if you don't really know the
exact types it's hard to catch all the
differences but there are all kinds of
different water slide manufactures and
different sizes for water slides like
regular family water slides or water
slides that you ride with some kind of
little rafts or turbo water slides
regardless they're all slightly
different anyway at this point I'm
almost done with the new window slides
that we've entered in this episode and
just at the end of the last one it's a
bit of an experiment I figured this
would be a water slide to use with a
little raft and would be cool to have
this Emin where it goes down in the open
air very similar to the assembly and the
multi-lane racer right next to it which
is something that you do kind of see
sometimes so I figured that would be fun
to try also I really needed just needed
the water slide to go down like quite a
bit just before it hits the end so that
it ends very close to the other water
slides and in a similar way and that
pretty much just rounds up these new
towers and they're not really towers per
se they are actually pretty small
they're not very tall to slice but this
is also some kind of build up that I was
trying to go for I really wanted to
sort of build up the heights of the
water slides toward the the big kamikaze
slides in the middle which are falling
from that super tall tower but the rest
is just a little bit shorter and more
using the natural terrain with these
hills along the sides of the swimming
pool also another reason why I was kind
of forced to set it up like this is
because we're hitting the park corner
and I have to be honest is actually the
first time ever that a park border has
been an issue for me at least in terms
of the entire park not really fitting
inside of it because I have to make
everything a little bit more compact
then I kind of wanted to over here
because otherwise we're hitting the park
border but on the other side of the park
where you've got the Bora Bora hook so
Kuala beach is really just about as big
as you can make a park and planet
coaster not sure where we're going to
even expand this at some point in the
future but it's getting very large at
this point so yeah that's basically the
slides pretty much finished and I wanted
to get to a little bit of scenery to
that as well so I did what is probably
best to do in case you want to steal
something and steal for myself and take
that quick beach fence and then kind of
stop for a second I could take some
textures from really swimming pool and
put those along the sides of the water
slides but I didn't really figure that
made too much sense at this time but
that said I am a little bit worried
about just putting the wooden planks
right next to the runners for them what
are slides like this because it's it
would and it doesn't really work too
well especially since these things tend
to splash a lot and I don't have some
kind of water caching mechanism on the
side of these things but that's maybe
something to think about for another day
at this point I just really wanted to
place rocks and foliage and make
with them look a little bit more fancy
before I had it on to the boring stuff
so I also experimented a little bit more
with using all the different books and
kind of accenting the rocks using the
lights bushes and using the darker
forest and jungle bushes as actual heavy
sort of foliage accents and I'm happy
with that I'll add a few palm trees and
stuff to it as well in the end to give
it that focal touch but the way that the
bushes work together with the rocks is
something that I still do quite like
especially in in the tropical setting
err
so here I wanted to build the start of
the waterslide because we're still
really missing that and it's nothing
really too complicated I'm going to keep
it simple enough so that basic shapes
will do it which does mean that it's a
little bit blocky but it will save a bit
of time and otherwise things might have
also just become extremely complicated
normally these things are much more
rounded and it's especially the
transition from the round pipe the water
slide into the square sort of styling
position that you're in
it's kind of hard to get right using
just all of these simple eyepieces but I
think this more or less does it with a
couple of sci-fi pieces as the water
pumps speaking of which I will also add
a few water pumps on the towers of the
water slides themselves just for realism
you have to have somewhere where you're
actually putting all of the water up to
the water slides themselves so that's
something to do as well but yeah that's
that's really all just maintenance and
trying to fix what we've built before
and make everything up to the standards
that are all right so here I went back
to for example the tower of the the
biggest slides that we have in here
because they didn't really have any
fences so that was a bit of a
adventurous situation there that needed
to be fixed quite quickly
I'm also worrying a little bit about the
cue lines since we don't have any and
that's a bit of an issue but
we're now actually going to keep it
largely like this it actually works
alright by adding some railings in the
middle of the big Tower but for the
other colored water slides it is quite
hard to add cue lines now I don't reckon
and I'm not sure about this you really
need it too badly for stuff like a
family slide or the multi Lane racer
especially since those things have much
bigger throughput but especially for
some of those very long typical standard
body slides there's always some kind of
guide in there and always some kind of
curing mechanism and terrible lines but
in this case I'm not too sure what we're
going to do with that also it do need a
little bit of scenery
eventually alongside the new site as
well and actually build some quick
wooden constructions to support all of
that but really with that done the
entire waterslide segments of Quanah
Beach is so far done and I'm not sure
what I might add to it in the future I
have no idea what the lady's honor or
really might add to it in the future
but so far I'm quite happy with it maybe
we'll keep it like this maybe we'll add
some stuff to it we're going to have to
have some talks about that I guess but
this is what we have so far and yeah I
think that rounds up everything quite
nicely and makes it look like it's not
too unfinished even though there's still
some space for it to be expanded upon
that's all for today so thank you guys
for watching and I hope to see you in
the next episode hopefully with the
ladies honor and rhudi again
[Music]